Africa / language culture and conflict
but United in demography the continent
is young populations are swelling in its
mega cities its workforce could reach
1.6 billion by 2060 almost triple what
it is today
in that time Africa's economy could grow
even more dramatically from 1.7 trillion
to over 15 trillion that's an increase
in per capita GDP from 1600 to $5,600
impressive growth but for reference it's
just a third of today's income in South
Korea in those atomic trend lines assume
continued foreign direct investment and
for that African leaders will have to
guarantee stability the numbers and the
odds are daunting most of the world's
fragile states are in Africa among them
Egypt in Libya for an idea of how
quickly investment can dry up in
sub-saharan Africa consider the economic
impact of the Arab Spring of North North
Africa saw nearly 30 percent decline in
projects funded by FBI last year at the
same time sub-saharan Africa still saw
an almost 5 percent increase perhaps
Nigeria home to one in five Africans and
poised to pass the US and population by
2050 best represents the continents
hopes and its Khazars GDP could reach
1.4 trillion in 2030 but insurrections
and violence could shave off hundreds of
billions growth has exceeded 4 percent
annually for the past decade but its
economy relies on oil and gas which have
fed insurrections where they're
extracted and Boko Haram's kidnapping of
hundreds of Nigerian schoolgirls in the
north further fuels an anxiety about the
country's stability in Nigeria is not
the only country facing challenges with
its extraction industry there are 22
countries producing oil and gas in
Africa today in a decade there'll be 45